members denise are out they are starting  to climb again initial claims for  regular unemployment  are above 10 000 for the first time  that's since august and that's up 10  percent  from the week before and continued  claims which is the number of unemployed  workers filing  weekly also up by three percent now the  big jump was in the pandemic  unemployment assistance which gig  workers file  for more than 56 000 nevadans filed for  the  pandemic unemployment assistance also  known as pua last week  that is a 575 percent increase from the  previous week  dieter says that huge jump may be partly  due to some benefits  being extended by congress didn't